tonight is Game seven big deal between
the Los Angeles Dodgers and the Houston
Astros that's right yeah it's big folks
the stakes are high whoever wins gets to
turn down an invitation to the White
House that's quite a rare honor ya know
every little kid's dream every kid's
dream y'all have a good Halloween last
night you have a good time yeah this is
interesting in Wisconsin a child's
trick-or-treat bag was found to contain
meth yeah yeah on the bright side the
kid did manage to hit 19 houses in under
two minutes
[Applause]
9,000 pounds of candy of course some
videos of racially insensitive Halloween
costumes went viral today yeah yeah well
then people realize they were just
watching footage of a Washington
Redskins game so I looked out at the end
of the day yeah okay yeah I'm standing
by that one by the way I'm not backing
off of that one I don't care how much
you you oh you want this is just seeing
a true story at the White House I guess
there's some kind of event First Lady
Melania Trump came across a
trick-or-treater dressed up as her she
bumped into her yeah
Melania spent several minutes trying to
convince the kid to switch places
how else is going on of course Trump's
former campaign manager Paul metaphor it
is in a lot of trouble
yeah you've learned your parts well yeah
no it's come out that this year indicted
Trump advisor Paul Manafort traveled to
Mexico using a fake name
went to Mexico using a fake name yeah
then again if you work for Trump and you
were in Mexico would you use your real
name
you put on a fake mustache you do
whatever you have to do you look like
Paul Manafort
no people have recently discovered a
property that Paul Manafort listed on
Airbnb yeah
of course it's not helping man afford
that it's a 2-bedroom condo in Moscow
that's that's right at the looks right
at the Kremlin it's gonna be today is
obscene today president Trump's press
secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders confirmed that no
one in president Trump's administration
supports slavery now to put that in
perspective the last press secretary who
had to make that statement work for
ulysses s grant
so we're against slavery are they better
phone that one in hello hello chief
you